- [Announcer] This Great Big Story
was made possible by Fairmont-
an ACCOR Hotels experience.
- A lot of people ask, well, what does
the Shanghai Restoration Project mean?
And it's inspired by the
1930s Shanghai jazz scene.
♪ Do do do do ♪
Back then, you had musicians
from all different cultural backgrounds
that came together to make a music
that couldn't be attributed
to any particular culture or nationality.
What we wanted to do was
sort of revive this spirit.
My name is Dave Liang.
- My name is Sun Yunfan.
- [Dave] We're the Shanghai
Restoration Project.
♪ Do do do do ♪
The Shanghai Restoration Project
has been around since 2005.
- We started performing as a duo,
I think the first time, in 2016.
We produced maybe 14, 15 albums.
These are some of the
artworks that I've done
for our album covers.
- We've played at the
Rio Cinema in London,
the Concrete & Grass Festival in Shanghai;
played the Great Wall of china.
(upbeat music)
- I grew up in China,
and Dave grew up here
but to a Chinese immigrant family.
When we first met I would ask him, like,
"Why do you use so many
Chinese instruments?"
I never listened to Chinese
folk musicians growing up.
- [Dave] Growing up I listened
to all sorts of genres,
but the one thing that just stuck out
were these Chinese instruments.
You know, in my home, they were just
like nothing else that I heard.
- [Sun] I think our merge of culture,
merge of perspectives
also influence our music.
(upbeat music)
- [Dave] What you'll hear
in our music are harmonic, rhythmical,
melodic influences from
all over the world.
You'll hear sounds from China.
You'll hear sounds from Brazil,
influences from Senegal or Ethiopia
or France or Portugal.
- [Sun] The process of creating
a new sound is always different.
We use a lot of samples
from every day objects.
- We tend to go to a lot of random places
for touring or for travel
and every place has a very unique sound.
- Sometimes when we are on trip,
a sound in the street,
we'll just like take
our phone or a recorder
to record the sound.
- We were in London
at the Tate museum
Yunfan had bought a poster
and she just started
hitting it against her leg
and hear it is
in the song Library Break In.
(slow bright music)
I think a lot
of these unique sounds generally will make
their way into our music.
The whole idea is that the world is small.
And that sounds are something
that can bring everybody together.
- [Sun] We feel like today's world
is much more interconnected.
And living in New York or Shanghai today,
that's what we see in our lives
and that reflects in our music.
(audience cheering)